(lively music)
- [Narrator] The price of lithium
has been going through the roof.
Why?
Because it's the key ingredient
in rechargeable batteries used
in everything from smartphones
to electric vehicles.
And as governments and
companies increasingly move away
from carbon-fueled economies,
those batteries are in
higher demand than ever.
- Traders and companies are betting
that there won't be enough lithium supply
to meet demand in the years ahead.
- [Narrator] There's actually
a lot of lithium available
all over the world.
Most current production comes
from Chile and Australia.
While the extraction
process is relatively easy,
converting it into battery-grade
chemicals is tough.
Producers are also facing
environmental pushback.
(protestor shouting in foreign language)
- [Narrator] These factors
have electric vehicle makers worried
that they won't be able to
secure enough of the metal,
and that could hinder the transition
to a low-carbon future.
- The future of
transportation in our nation
and around the world is electric.
- [Narrator] As big automakers like Tesla,
Ford and General Motors
increase production
of electric cars, demand
for lithium is multiplying.
Analysts expect the size
of the lithium market
to more than double by 2025.
But right now, supply is tight.
Once lithium is mined,
which itself can take a long time,
it's then sent to places like China
where the metal gets converted
into the chemicals needed for batteries.
- China is the world leader
in processing these
battery-grade chemicals.
So that's a major concern
for US companies and politicians,
but you could also see
how shipping the stuff
all over the world creates a
very cumbersome supply chain.
- [Narrator] Still, companies
and investors see lithium
as a huge market opportunity
as the transition to a
greener economy picks up pace.
- Because some people are saying
that lithium could be the
21st century version of oil
and that securing supply is so important,
you see a lot of companies really trying
to invest and produce,
and that race is really
playing out everywhere
because again, lithium is abundant.
It's just about getting
it out of the ground
and finding a kind of low-cost way
and more sustainable way really
to convert it into
battery-grade chemicals.
- [Narrator] As more
companies get involved
in lithium production,
analysts expect total supply
from countries like Australia and Chile
to eventually exceed demand
and cool the price rally in
the coming months and years.
Mining giant Rio Tinto is one
of the many players getting
involved in the lithium market.
The company recently
announced an $825 million deal
to buy a lithium project in Argentina.
But projects all over the world
are being met with opposition.
(crowd shouting)
- In Serbia in December 2021,
we saw a lot of protests
and thousands of protestors
in Belgrade blocking bridges
to protest Rio Tinto's plans
to invest over $2 billion
there for lithium production.
- [Narrator] Environmentalists argue
that mining lithium can
require a lot of water
and that chemicals used in production
can leak into nearby water supplies
and harm the surroundings.
- A Rio Tinto spokesman even told me
that they're not really going
to sacrifice the big picture
for local concerns.
One reason some investors are
really bullish moving forward,
if protestors and others concerned
about the environmental impact
won't let these companies
produce the commodities
that are needed to make
the electric vehicles,
then people see higher prices,
and supply scarcity and volatility ahead.
(dramatic music)